yellow welcome to this video a new 15
minute game after a longer break yet the
good news is that my colt is almost gone
so I hope to be able to play this video
without any distraction of me m yes
nessing or something like that but I'm
still very busy with my move to the new
apartment so I really have very little
time to do videos but i managed to on
play this 15-minute game here and it
started out as a modern defense with g 6
36 and t6 and yeah what isn't exactly a
subtle hear about his plans threatening
mate on f7 on their almost made on f7
but i can i can cover it with mud f6 and
as long as II 45 isn't coming um it
should be fine for me so Bishop g5 yeah
the question is should I play if I've
stride away straightaway yeah I think
it's a good idea to attack our deform
instantly his bishop moves and Queen
moves have neglected the default square
so with e5 I'm immediately applying
pressure on deform and term yeah he can
cover it with nighty too but I'm not
sure how came yeah this looks like a
weird move combined with the bishop on
on see form the only good thing probably
is that I cannot go to e7 s of6 is
hanging but the aid isn't such a bad
place for the night anyway so I don't
mind that at all
because in the long run it can go to c5
and has got down good squares and the
future um the problem is however the pin
I'd like to prepare a five but as long
as he's in this pin it's some this is a
bit annoying I can play h6 ng5 but i'm
not sure if i if i want to do that that
weakens f5 considerably maybe not a big
deal but don't like it like it so much
you know what I don't want to do now is
castle I mean this this doesn't really
help me canceling cam I'm wondering h2h
65 and night fa to g6 maybe I don't
really I'm not totally convinced about
all this because I'm weakening f5 very
much but it's hard to imagine how to
make any progress without that
and maybe yeah maybe it's going to eat
three after all you never know yeah now
it's um it's interesting he may be a min
tends to play g4 even and try to really
put a bind on the kingside what what arm
my possibilities see I can play h5 h5
Bishop h6 could be an idea but h 4g for
could could be the problem i think i can
on g who I can play h form maybe you can
play Bishop g5 this was too quick yeah G
for each for Bishop g5 is probably
probably know yeah maybe it's still ok
but I didn't really pay too much
attention to this G for h1 would be
positionally nice the ideas night h7 is
going for the pin immediately yeah yeah
thought I could play Bishop h6 really to
get rid of their somewhat bad bishop all
right each form but I can take a night
h7 right don't I win the pawn yeah I
think I win the pawn
yeah i mean this hy that didn't work um
get technically so the same this point
is just dropping but strategically this
isn't such a bad bad idea this h4 try to
establish a pawn here but you really
need to establish it you lose it
instantly it doesn't have a tall can
only cover it with night eh h3 but i can
just take them i'm on this pawn twice oh
this is really a really desperate
measure probably banking on on my pre
move let x g5 but really no use in free
moving in a rapid game yeah actually i
had done hmm the search out for for this
game for for like close to five minutes
and still the auto pairing system paired
me with the player with the 1600 rating
so a little bit of a mismatch it's not
easy sometimes to get opponents of
similar strength in in rapid at least
it's not much of a problem in three
minutes or five minutes but rapid is
simply less popular among the let's say
title players simply takes much much
more time and they really am are often
on there for just short while to to play
some some simple adoro blitz chess ok i
just need to activate pieces now I'm
just the rook up I could have played
night g5 also
at night chief I mean it's just Nick sir
look it's not done oh yeah yeah well
just just interpose here it doesn't have
any any kind of attack you mean the
queen is very far away from from my king
if it would would be lets say ready to
capture on b7 or something that might be
might be a little bit of swindling
chances but the queen is too far away
ephraim the other one you need to need
to try something if you are a whole look
down yeah I guess I'll I'll occupy the
squares here defined after taking on fo
probably go to e5 yeah I think I should
also take this tempo attacking the Queen
and I can take on f4 next move in this
case I might even play Knight h5 you
know let's let's just win a form its own
that's better
it's really honestly speaking not much
point in continuing this but ok ok some
go to check on b5 but I can just go to
see a tantrum it's really just a check
yeah well some general remarks as
mentioned I'm still very am busy with my
my move it it's really amazing how much
work moving to a new apartment can be
really am much much more time then then
I am initially thought I hope I'm done
in about two weeks and then the channel
will also return to much more regular
updates like it has been up to the last
two or three weeks so almost daily
updates but up for the next to two to
three weeks I really have so much other
stuff to do I already cannot cannot do
anything on the channel especially not
things that actually require preparation
I mean those kind of game analysis of
Grandmaster games are opening surveys
and I I don't do this do this without
any preparation I mean obviously
obviously some some other chest channels
do do two videos just like yeah without
any prep just telling whatever but I'm
actually invest quite some time to to
prepare them and I hope it shows in them
and the quality but this also means I
cannot do them like in 20 minutes
yeah that's a 20 minute video requires
at least two hours for me to prepare and
do all the things and then I cannot do
this at the moment so please bear with
me until this this movement is finished
yeah okay just gave him yet another
exchange and yeah basically the only way
to to lose this game as black as to to
mouth slip rookie 82 Queen takes the a
checkmate yeah no I'm getting I don't
get a three but it looks very suspicious
we need to is almost checkmate it's just
covered by the Queen um b5 yeah and rook
h3 actually runs into a Queenie a
checkmate so okay so let's play a 6 down
to attack the Queen and it goes to it
doesn't have many squares probably to
see form then I can play rogue age three
and then thus we should should be
answered by resigns I don't really see a
move after that oops yeah well then then
I'll give their immediate meteor yeah
the Sun netted me 11.1 rating point yeah
okay this wasn't them too long of a game
I'll try to search for another one but
then it's really maybe is also related
to to the time of day as Sam it's in the
morning here German time and
means a nighttime in the US and this
excludes quite a large amount of
opponents so maybe i'll get to get
another game after seek out and help to
hope to get paired alternatively i could
could play a couple of blitz games but
i'll try to wait like 30 seconds off to
a minute and if this doesn't turn up an
opponent down i'll change the time for
the for the seek yeah also what will be
featured on the channel um and I think
in early early December so I don't know
maybe in a week or about a week I think
the London chest classics will start
very nice tournament very strong
tournament also i think featuring among
others um carlton and nakamura I think
kramnik also in the mix I'm not one
hundred percent sure I didn't I really
have a little bit i can i can take a
look quickly i know it is it's very
strong as as usual well I'm can't close
to see who's who's in there let's let's
see
okay so we have Carlton la camara pulga
Micky Adams Kramnik aronian Luke McShane
Devane Jones and vision oh yeah great
Lane great lineup they also have this
nine player Foreman so one players
always am yeah having a rest rest day so
to st. can assist in the in the
comentary this was always am always nice
and let's see the starting round has got
aronia nakamura McShane Carlton kramnik
polgar and Jones atoms and the first
round is actually December first yeah
okay let's let's check yeah my schedule
term date for my for my movers couple of
days later so maybe I'll do some can do
some wrap up videos or something I hope
that the internet and and stuff in the
new apartment is working yeah I don't
get a 15 minute game so i'll try for
else a 50 game and let's see oh pretty
high rated opponent to 410 and we get
them dutch defense okay let's play some
sideline I'm not too well at why some on
the main line that I'd like I like those
those sidelines actually yeah I think it
can allow Eve form it's not such a big
deal oh ok probably mmm no not sure
maybe Queen d2 wasn't so great i'm sort
of playing this sir on Don general
grounds I don't know don't notice he
really
yeah okay I don't have much short I need
to go here and this admittedly looks
like a somewhat weird play by me hmm
yeah probably i need to take and play if
also black has some is quite an open
King side so it's um it shouldn't be a
really bad for white I mean I lost some
time with my bishop but down hard to
believe that I still shouldn't be okay
young my deaf three maybe pushes g-form
so when I go here d 5 is the issue I'm
quite a week on the dark squares and um
five my tongue might be a good way to
take advantage of that yeah let's make
sense question is what should I do I
mean d5 is Sam is probably am nonsense
it would kill my bishop if I take you
probably take both the night and we
should be three in and probably f4 x
black I don't know how to how to assess
this but it shouldn't be too bad for him
probably a probably this is fine for
black hmm hard to tell should I allow
him to take on default looks strange
goodnight b5 getting the porn back yeah
probably i need to take Queen and night
takes we should be three okay it doesn't
take with the night this look them very
natural to me okay
okay so I mean I need to try to get to
ask in here yeah well 95 looks like a
normal move but b2 is hanging not sure
that this is really an issue but that it
could be king be one Queen g7 and c3 and
then then this Bishop is stranded would
need to go to a three yeah so I'm not
sure if I if I trust this maybe go out
of them out of the checks out that I'm
threatening 95 hmm isn't this isn't this
so quite good take here now I have to
the idea should be five also and maybe
you can just place these 6 cm now an
estimated this a bit you can place your
60 without much of a problem okay so
let's say let's cover this and try to
play f4 maybe he plays F for himself
this is a possibility yeah there then
you need to try to go 96
yeah yeah I've also more concerned about
night g6 with the idea to to get this
piece to e5 quickly this is why I played
Bishop d3 to to just to just take it the
theme if you place an IG 6 hmm ok once
ago to f6 70 k yeah but down on time I
was some more more in a 15-minute minute
mode and spend far too much time of
course black itself perfectly okay here
probably am just just some such as just
better with the snide and his King also
his son is quicker in joining the the
plan there in the center
yeah this is just a good position for
black I have this really sunny bishop
and also the time issue not sure how bad
it is i mean probably it's um it's still
on still halfway halfway decent but ok
yeah yeah i will look this mmm cannot
cannot protect the five now yeah just 93
would have been stronger you okay white
resides yeah I am I was left with them I
misjudged this this position probably
was 97 I thought I had Bishop b5 and
would spoil his canceling rides but he
can just place his six and maybe here I
need to play something um something more
aggressive maybe a for something my
computer actually recommends g 3g 3 + f4
yeah I had the feeling that something
like this should be ok but i wanted to i
just wanted to have it convenient with
c3 and then player for but now player
for himself and maybe this was what's
too accommodating I don't know
yeah yeah the computer actually gives an
idea of night see 1 2 D 3 and rookie one
with a pretty substantial advantage yeah
I don't know it's a it's complicated and
as I spent too much time before that
okay so let's try for another game I'll
even also search for a 15 minute game
but it's unlikely to get one yeah but
you did a good job here I mean this now
here h4 rh4 should really play h4 here
je took the wrong rookie and actually it
should probably take the other one each
for now it's also looks looks okay using
the the H farm yeah this is probably
even good for white yeah of this this
now I'm is simply a black advantage
maybe I'm almost certainly you can
defend better than I did but so it's
really annoying now
game started okay a five-minute game and
it's money for let's play the French and
see what what Linus is coming up with 93
yeah let's play the the classical line
Knight f6 nowadays the main line and the
mech caption variation is quite
interesting this should be for ya
Corinne g4 is the old main line and now
black and choose between g6 and king of
a day I don't know I don't know both
moves to be honest I'm just playing the
surf on general grounds okay this is
interesting is sort of offering me the
c3 porn but probably I cannot take it
I'm just assuming that I cannot take it
probably c5 is right intending Queen 85
okay we responded quickly so maybe
ourselves right cooney five maybe I
really don't know what's what the book
would move here that looks dangerous
maybe check on g4 I can take on e4 now i
am at the end i take him we had the
problem is that my dark squares are
really really weak this cone could get
ugly not quite sure where to them what
to put my king I mean I cannot Castle
short with h6 and g6 song being played
and long castle some also look Sam
rather rather risky and this is some
putting it mildly hmm yeah just Bishop
you said no can I get the Queen's of
some of summer Queen before but you can
just move the Queen to you three RF
three so the same probably am wouldn't
help at all so yeah just Bishop d7 I
don't know yeah I don't like this
position much i always prefer positions
were done with the safe king and mucking
won't be safe here for a long time yeah
i simply try to to get get since e3 porn
understandably
yeah yeah maybe to e4 somewhere okay
maybe I can recoup the night and turn
when we can play Bishop c6 something
like this of course I'm also attacking
the night song is some probably needs to
to cover it and he dealt with the 2d too
so maybe here to to cover your form so
that he cannot play 94 I can actually
move as long as the queen is here maybe
you can play this movie I'm taking the
Queen and if he takes Queen takes our I
threaten a mate so okay
yeah what can you do i need to take here
maybe queen a for after that nice would
be an to play h5 and h4 stuff like that
h 5 h for using the rook or h5 queen a
queen g-form to make sure that the
Queen's come off now that the case it
always looks shaky with this old cg 7
f-6 and so on but it doesn't have so
many pieces to to attack really probably
it's not so dangerous I'd have very good
Bishop on 60 it's not all all doom and
gloom here hmm ok he wants to probably
em do something only seven if i go here
maybe maybe rooks III don't know i need
to also speed up a bit
yeah i'm not sure if he has a really
good square now oops yeah well the
exchanges it's just nothing of course
it's it's equal i am i'm not not saying
that I'm better or something but it's
it's not not a problem anymore it really
needs to keep Queens on so here can I
can maybe you try a bit some the sea
porn is somewhat weak well ok it's a
passport not i can i can conveniently
block this with King Lucy six push up
here and then I can try to push the beep
on
guys miss bishop on d6 is not I'm
learning so much really from here I can
I can play me form oh can I can try to
to play ok he allows me to play before
so I go I go ahead and do it now okay
listen this pawn I cannot do much about
but I'll activate my row can't have a
really strong strong be porn here I know
I actually threatened to take on on c5
couldn't take before because of Bishop
f8 but now he covers c 5 i'll take
whoops such a silly Tector again yeah
this is frustrating it was a was just
great for black and now I did them I did
overlook this alright I hope it's still
a draw
yeah that's a fairly easy draw even
check gras Harvard game draw now I could
win on time is just very slow yeah I
just silly I completely completely
overlooked there would be three of
course I think probably other moves just
win just something normal King be five
or whatever and the big bonus is too
strong King be five here computer one
stop liking be five but probably even
other moves are good okay for or
something just not the one I played
blundering plundering to rook takes me
three yeah all right um thanks for
watching the video i'll i'll stop now or
almost 40 minutes um completed yeah
thanks for watching I hope to be to be
back soon but yeah please bear with me
in this somewhat complicated time so
that there are less updates but it's
just a matter of time until the regular
service returns so the same yeah why